en esta ocasión nos piden emparejar cada
función con el intervalo en el que
aparece en la gráfica siguiente esta es
la gráfica y como ven tenemos aquí dos
funciones una con esta forma y otra con
esta y aquí abajo nos están poniendo las
fórmulas que podrían estar relacionadas
con estas gráficas y el intervalo en el
que valen noten que aquí tenemos varios
intervalos 2 menor o igual que x y x
menor a 6 pero no menor o igual en la
gráfica las bolitas cerradas significan
que es este punto o igual a este punto
las bolitas abiertas significan que son
mayores menores pero no iguales a este
punto entonces vamos a analizar algunos
puntos de estas gráficas para
identificar los intervalos de los puntos
y las funciones que les corresponden
para esto vamos a usar nuestro pizarrón
electrónico para poder hacer algunas
anotaciones con mayor facilidad aquí
está
en esta parte he acomodado las gráficas
en este lado y todas las opciones de
fórmulas de las gráficas e intervalos
vamos a analizar cada uno de ellos
veamos aquí cuál es el rango que estoy
viendo en esta gráfica bueno aquí tengo
que este valor es un -3 y como es un
punto cerrado es un -3 que toca a este
valor menos 3 es igual puede ser en este
caso vemos que la gráfica va hacia la
derecha es mayor
o igual a menos 3 como la gráfica va de
aquí a acá y es un punto cerrado esta
esta función de aquí al menos en esta
parte es de menos 3 así que esto de aquí
que continua de la función va a ser
mayor o igual que menos 3 y de este otro
lado vemos que la función llega a este 2
pero no lo toca porque tiene este punto
abierto entonces esto va a ser nuestra x
mayor o igual que menos 3 y va a ser
menor pero no igual solo menor que 2 y
ese es el intervalo de esta función así
que vamos a ver que caemos aquí en ese
intervalo de menos 3 menor o igual a x
menor que 2
al menos para esta función aquí vamos a
caer y ahora veamos nuestra segunda
gráfica esta también va a caer aquí en
el 2 pero como tiene un punto cerrado
este valor en x esta función se iba a
alcanzar al 2 entonces este 2 es menor o
igual por el punto cerrado veamos cuál
es el otro valor extremo es el 6 pero no
lo toca por este por este punto abierto
entonces nuestra x va a ser menor pero
no igual que 6 no lo va a tocar y ese es
el rango de esta otra función veamos
cuál es el que tenemos en el 2 - no
2 aquí está 2 menor o igual que x menor
que 6
este es nuestro otro rango y ahora
queremos ver cuáles estas funciones
corresponden a estas gráficas para esto
lo más fácil es encontrar puntos en x y
ver su valor en y sustituir el valor de
la x en estas fórmulas y ver si nos dan
el mismo valor de y entonces para más
seguridad vamos a evaluar o encontrar
dos puntos en cada gráfica para ver si
ambos puntos se cumplen en alguna de
nuestras fórmulas aquí para encontrar
cuál corresponde veamos
el valor si me en este caso me x vale
menos 3 que aquí en esta parte de la
fórmula si lo toca entonces este punto
de acá sus coordenadas son menos 3
coma 6
vamos a encontrar otro punto pues bueno
este como que me gusta este de aquí
cuando x es igual a 0
y va a valer menos 3 ahora vamos a ver
si estos puntos se cumplen en alguna de
estas fórmulas
en eso nos tenemos que sustituir el
valor de x vamos a comenzar con este que
es menos 3
en esta
tenemos menos tres menos dos va a ser
menos cinco menos cinco al cuadrado 5
por 5 25 menos por menos es más 16 más
25 sería esto 16 más 25 va a ser 44
entonces esto será igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 44 pero con este menos 3
sabemos que nuestras ya debe ser 6 y no
sé cuánto sea la raíz de 44 pero seguro
que no es 66 por 6 636 así que está para
esta gráfica no es bueno veamos la
siguiente aquí es menos 3
- 3 - 12 5 - 5 al cuadrados 25 4
25 es 21 esto sería raíz de 21 pero de
nuevo raíz de 21 no es 6 6 por 6 636 así
que está tampoco nos sirve para esta
gráfica
la siguiente
de nuevo menos tres menos 12 55 al
cuadrados 25 16 25 va a ser igual a
menos 9
y de hecho esto sería menos de aquí
arriba me confundí pero bueno menos 9 la
raíz cuadrada de menos 9 estrés esta
sería 3 pero la que estamos buscando es
6 así que no nos sirve eso tampoco nos
sirve ahora está aquí tenemos menos tres
más dos es menos 1 al cuadrado es 116
menos 1 es 15 así que es la raíz
cuadrada de 15 y la raíz cuadrada de 15
tampoco va a ser 6 está no nos sirve
veamos menos 3
menos tres es menos seis menos seis al
cuadrado es 36 éste tampoco ok
- x al cuadrado más 3 menos
x es menos 3 al cuadrado esto es 3 x 39
entonces es menos 9 lo pongo aquí arriba
menos 9 más 3 es igual a menos 6 no
tampoco nos sirve esto vamos a ver esta
última menos 3 el cuadrado va a ser 9
menos 39 menos 3 es igual a 6 vaya está
si es esta fórmula corresponde a esta
gráfica al menos en este punto para
confirmar la vamos a analizar con este
otro punto si x es igual a 0
si esto es 0 0 al cuadrado sigue siendo
0 el resultado es menos 3 que es este de
aquí así que si ya checamos que ésta nos
sirve y cómo es este intervalo pues
vamos a elegir este puntito de aquí o
que ya encontramos la fórmula para una
de estas funciones ahora vamos a
analizar la siguiente gráfica
y lo vamos a usar con otro color para
diferenciar nuevamente encontramos
puntos en esta gráfica para poder
evaluar vamos a ver este punto que es el
x es 2
y es 4 podemos elegir este punto de aquí
no saben que este punto mejor no este no
vamos a tomar este punto de aquí que es
cuando x igual a 6 y es igual a 0
60 s creo que va a ser más fácil de
evaluar entonces tomamos la primera
sustituimos en esta x este 22 menos 1200
al cuadrado sigue siendo 0 nos queda que
esto es raíz cuadrada de 16 y la de es
cuadrada de 16 es 4 4 por 4 16 así que
estos se están cumpliendo vamos a ver
para este otro punto si yo tomo 6 y lo
sustituyó aquí en la x 6 menos 2 me
queda 44 al cuadrado de 1616 más 16 va a
ser igual a 32 y esto sería la raíz
cuadrada de 32 que bueno no cumple con
esto así que ésta no nos sirve ahora
vamos a analizar la siguiente vamos a
sustituir nuestro 2 aquí en dos menos
1200 al cuadrado 0 nos queda 4
esto sería raíz de 4
es nuestra raíz cuadrada de 4 es 2 pero
no coincide con esta x de aquí así que
ésta tampoco nos sirve veamos aquí 2 200
al cuadrado 0 16 - 0 nos queda 16 esa es
la raíz cuadrada de 16 que es 4
este podría cumplir ya que nos da estas
coordenadas vamos a evaluar estas seis
menos dos es 44 al cuadrado es 16 16
menos 16 es raíz de 0 que es ser así que
ésta nos da como resultado un 0 que
coincide con esto está así nos
funcionaría y nada más por no dejar
vamos a revisar las otras que no
coinciden con estos puntos 2 más 2 es 44
al cuadrado es 16 16 menos 16 es cero
ésta no nos sirve porque no cumple con
este punto
aquí 2 - 3 - 1 - 1 al cuadrado es 1 10
sería igual a 1 que no cumple con esto
este tampoco es aquí es menos 2 al
cuadrado es 4 menos 4 3 es menos uno que
tampoco coincide con esto de aquí esto
no va finalmente 2 al cuadrado es 4
menos 3 es 1 y eso sería 1 así que este
tampoco cumple por lo que el que nos
interesa en este intervalo es este
todos los demás irían aquí en ninguno al
menos para lo que nos interesa vamos a
ver en la plataforma
estos resultados aquí bajamos un poco
quedamos que está no está tampoco está
si ésta no está no está no y está aquí y
veamos nuestra respuesta es correcta